C'est à ce moment-là, quand vous êtes perdu, inquiet ou abandonné,
que vous découvrez qui vous êtes.
Je ne pense pas que l'ignorance soit bénie.
La science a sans conteste rendu nos vies
plus joyeuses, plus longues et plus saines.
Je serai toujours reconnaissant envers ceux qui m'ont enseigné la physique
et démontré que trois fois trois font neuf.
Je peux le compter sur mes doigts,
n'importe quand.
Mais quand un mathématicien me dit
que -3 multiplié par -3 font 9,
ce genre de logique tiendrait presque de la foi.
Autrement dit, l'opposé de la connaissance n'est pas toujours l'ignorance.
Ça peut être l'émerveillement.
Ou le mystère.
La possibilité.
Dans ma vie, j'ai découvert que les choses que je ne connaissais pas
m'ont aidé et fait avancer
bien plus que celles que je connaissais.
Ce sont les choses que j'ignorais
qui m'ont le plus rapproché de mon entourage.
Ces huit derniers mois de novembre,
j'ai voyagé à travers le Japon avec le Dalaï Lama.
Et la chose qu'il répétait tous les jours,
qui semblait le plus rassurer et donner confiance aux gens,
c'était : « Je ne sais pas. »
« Que deviendra le Tibet ? »
« Quand est-ce que la paix arrivera dans le monde ? »
« Comment élever un enfant le mieux possible ? »
« Franchement, répondait cet homme très sage,
je ne sais pas. »
L'économiste et prix Nobel, Daniel Kahneman,
a passé plus de 60 ans à étudier le comportement humain
et sa conclusion,
c'est que nous sommes plus confiants en ce que nous croyons savoir
que nous devrions l'être.
Nous avons, comme il le dit si bien,
une « capacité illimitée à ignorer l'ignorance ».
Nous savons, pour le citer, que notre équipe gagnera ce week-end
et nous ne retenons que cela,
les rares occasions où nous avons raison.
La plupart du temps, nous sommes dans les ténèbres.
Et c'est là que se trouve la véritable intimité.
Savez-vous ce que votre amant fera demain ?
Voulez-vous vraiment le savoir ?
Nos parents à tous, comme certains les appellent,
Adam et Eve,
ne pouvaient pas mourir,
du moment qu'ils mangeaient les fruits de l'arbre de la vie.
Mais la minute où ils mangèrent les fruits
de l'arbre de la connaissance du bien et du mal,
ils perdirent leur innocence.
Ils grandirent honteux et irritables,
conscients d'eux-mêmes.
Ils ont appris, sans doute un peu trop tard,
qu'il y a des choses bonnes à savoir,
mais il y en a beaucoup, beaucoup d'autres qu'il faudrait laisser inexplorées.
Quand j'étais jeune,
je savais tout, bien sûr,
j'avais passé 20 ans à l'école à amasser les faits
et je travaillais dans le secteur de l'information,
à écrire des articles pour le magazine Time.
J'ai fait mon premier voyage au Japon pendant deux semaines et demi
et je suis revenu avec un essai de 40 pages
expliquant jusqu'aux moindres détails le Japon, ses temples,
ses modes, ses matchs de baseball,
son âme.
Mais en-dessous de tout ça,
quelque chose que je ne comprenais pas
m'a ému pour des raisons que je n'arrivais pas encore à expliquer
et cela m'a poussé à partir vivre au Japon.
Ça fait maintenant 28 ans que j'y suis,
je ne saurais vous en dire beaucoup
sur mon foyer d'adoption.
Et c'est merveilleux.
Ça veut dire que chaque jour, je découvre de nouvelles choses
et, dans le même temps,
je regarde autour de moi et je vois des centaines de milliers de choses
que je ne connaîtrai jamais.
Le savoir est un cadeau inestimable.
Mais l'illusion de la connaissance peut être plus dangereuse que l'ignorance.
Penser que vous connaissez votre amant
ou votre ennemi
peut être plus trompeur
que d'admettre que vous ne les connaîtrez jamais.
Chaque matin au Japon, quand le soleil illumine notre petit appartement,
je me force à ne pas consulter la météo,
car si je le fais,
mon esprit sera brumeux, distrait,
même quand le jour est clair.
Je suis écrivain à plein temps depuis 34 ans.
Et la chose que j'ai apprise,
c'est que le changement arrive quand je n'ai pas le contrôle,
quand je ne sais pas ce qui va arriver après,
quand je ne prétends pas être plus important que tout ce qui m'entoure.
C'est aussi vrai en amour
ou dans les moments de crise.
Tout à coup, nous revoilà dans le pousse-pousse,
nous traversons de larges rues bien éclairées
et nous nous rappelons de la première règle du voyage
et donc de la vie :
on est seulement aussi fort que notre disposition à lâcher prise.
Au bout du compte, peut-être,
être humain
est bien plus important
que d'être pleinement conscient.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)